a telephoto lens for your iPhone and
bacon flavored toothpaste it's episode
six of loot every dog should have a
bowtie and loyal luck sells a bunch
these scissors are like a paper shredder
and Ark what sells an old timey speaker
for your iPhone oh she makes socks that
form a heart when you put your feet
together or grab some that look like raw
meat pencils Mario warp zones or
cigarettes accessorize with nacho
bracelet charms or if it's early Eggs
Benedict you can carry them around in
your taco purse but if you prefer real
food use a pizza cutter that looks like
a circular saw ditch the fuzzy dice for
these plush Rubik's cubes and then take
a swig from your cellphone shaped flask
or celebrate with a flask that from the
bottom is a mustache if you prefer
champagne limit yourself to one glass or
if you're opening wine use a screw corn
or just tell the world screw you with
this middle finger shaped corkscrew is
the wine not cold well look it's okay to
use some ice cubes if they're in the
shape of Stewie's head or Playboy
Bunnies or yellow submarine's
r2d2 Han Solo in carbonite Tetris pieces
Legos bullets shoes sinking Titanic's or
a big ol guitar which you can also have
as your toilet handle of course
geometrically a sphere is the best way
to cool a drink with minimal dilution
via melting you can either use this ice
cube ball mold for 16 bucks or if you're
one of the many billionaires who watch
this show mccollins perfect sphere
cutter for over a thousand still have
money left well here's a twenty four
thousand dollar diamond and white gold
computer mouse or how about a wristwatch
covered in 201 carats of diamonds worth
25 million if your budget is smaller
just pick up this clock on Etsy what
time is it creepy o clock here's some
cute blue mountain comm lets you type in
a sentence and then email an animal
saying your words to someone
haha look at me I'm a talking cat be
sure to subscribe to Vsauce 2 and like
us on Facebook oh and one more thing
Michael is incredibly sexy if you prefer
your animals dead check out bone room
comm you can buy Bobcat claws for three
dollars each or a coyote claw for 75
cents a real alligator head for 15 bucks
or a piece of owl poop full of Mouse
bones you can dissect and collect for
250 if it gets too stinky plug in one of
Yenko designs USB powered fragrance
dispensers but my favorite is the entire
disarticulated skull every bone in the
human head is separated and suspended on
moveable wires on Facebook Cody showed
us this cool anatomical sleeping bag and
Sheila showed us a dress that can come
off and be used as a miniature putting
green be sure to subscribe to vsauce too
and like us on facebook and as always
thanks for watching